[Musique]
décarie on attends tu attaques spéciales
aujourd'hui du vrai que j'ai mis de la
partie des gains qu'elle y va on attend
comme tâche pékin aujourd'hui avec tous
les pony coeur qu'elles sont là bas
puisque c'est l'allemand dernière et
donc tu es chéri
ce sera le dernier toc toc toc de
l'histoire de dbm pays bonsoir à tous
arrêtons de vue cela ils sont derrière
n'a pas à les voir si l'on devrait avoir
de temps que je crache sa ligne non non
c'est la première toc toc
vas-y vas-y aller toc toc toc cayla il
fait été et l'été c'est qu'il est bon
attendez je vais les brides les bains
avait commencé par être allé en aucun
cas qu'il connaît des voix le parti
demande si on débat merci en fait le
dernier toc toc toc c'est le bordel
c'est l'avant dernière c'est la folie je
sais gérer
on va voir ça allez c'est parti regard
le coach est là c'est l'été les
techniques les téléphones est allé
s'asseoir
grosse surprise à la fin de ce toc toc
toc natation deuxième d'act up top c'est
parti
cayla l'été j'ai pas entendu top 10
c'est la personne qui est derrière est
ce qu elle peut me dire ça c'est rare
que je frappe si je veux dire tout le
temps quand même toit une attaque c'est
pour le rythme qui à l'été l'été qui
l'était chaos
[Musique]
ôté tous mes idéaux
mais bravo magnifique je sens que ça va
être très bien cette séquence attention
trois êtres d'autant qu'on sait que vous
aimez cette séquence et chérie c'est
parti je vends toc toc toc et au toc toc
toc et la cellulite et non pas vous je
rappelle à telle heure on passe à les
attaques n'ont pas vous non plus
merci pas vous le dire était en toc qui
est là jean michel le college or art et
toc toc toc qui est là mais qu'il était
est et qui sait qu'on met tait c'est ce
qu'il était c'est voler plus on n'a
jamais vu sur une chaîne des mecs lancer
une musique comme chez nous le gardien
et c'est qu'ils ont scandé à 28 me
saljic a insisté nul merci fermé la
porte mais la forme est là on n'est pas
bien on n'est pas chez votre médecin
merci et jean michel et moi ça chez eux
on va très bientôt dyneon sans le dire
exactement on a des choses à
l'inattention et vous j'ai des choses à
vous dire dès qu'ils aient la cgt je
reconnais la voix de beinheim c'est bien
mais là il que j'entends wee cc benhaim
l'été quoi benhaim l'été oui on la
refait donc tu attaques n'ont pas vous
quoi alors après star renvoyer moi
quelqu'un donc tu ne tient qu elle aa et
je l'avais reconnue et et qui était
alors
mais qu'est ce que ça te fait j'ai même
pas les protocoles lice idée fixe les
collés serrés copier coller et copier
coller
mais les consoler
un p'tit belgique ne fait pas de mal
attention c'est parti
le prochain toc toc toc toc toc toc il
est angoissé logar on avait précisé m on
a dépressif derrière la porte wiki et la
télé tnt qui était décidée ce mardi au
soleil
pas jusqu'à lui
il a toujours évolué chez les dames au
jeu l'adorent allez les chérit le coach
au quai ceineray s'attaque tout couac et
là c'est l'été à pau très mélangées
géraldine maillet j'ai trouvé qu'elle
était là l'été qui était ou mettez pas
la météo ou voit la météo
bravo géraldine vous étiez magnifique
2ème geraghty
je suis fan de cette femme et les
chiffres des comptes c'est
l'avant-dernière avant je suis en race
rama wali allez on y va
tac tac tac mais c'est le cgg qui c'est
l'été et et qui l'était moins c'est
chanter taper dedans mais ça y est je
crois que c'est moi yep yep yep yep
mais c'est moi danser c'est que chez
vous il ya deux jours oui et j'avais ma
bombe lacrymo clip c'est juste derrière
j'ai eu très très peur aux intérêts
mesquins
mais ce témoin et vous raconterai tout
ça demain sur le prime parce que ça va
être énorme
les chéris d'ailleurs demain ça va être
dès 19h la folie je vous le dis il y
aura une fan zone où on sera tous dans
la rue il va y avoir un concert un truc
ce serait de la folie je vous dis là
grands volets la folie à les toc toc toc
toc toc toc qui est là c'est l'été et et
qui les terres brûlées au vent de terre
autour mais l'accès pour les vivants
dans le connemara bâlois s'il n'est pas
dehors
j'ai de choléra
je guérisse et lycées
et vous aimez
harry attache au beau fixe et s'arme
total d'acs qui est là c'est l'été l'été
qui l'été venu le temps des cats s
écoutez la rancune à malemort à levante
bonheur
je pouvais arriver attention surprise à
à aller c'est quelqu'un de pas commode
là on dirait le voisin qui t'a pas ce
que tu as fait trop de bruit
oui quel à l'état qui
douchez
manger c'est que du bonheur oh
douchez touché
trop cher
[Musique]
chez la voisine
oh
allez la chapelle
ma culture est toujours là
m
[Musique]
john est précieux
m
à dieuze dangereux
g
[Musique]
oh
touché j'ai la touche r
lee
chez la chatte à la voisine
oh
[Musique]
6 2
oh
[Musique]
c'est parti
bruce wayne
cinquième au canada
[Musique]
c'est chaud
d'achat
ça
[Rires]
coup franc qui est ce que tu peux pas
nous faire un petit cousin de fruit de
la passion comme un pôle qui s'amusait
[Musique]
collé-serré doute qu elle connaissait
les doudous
[Musique]
terme c'est l'actuel manager captain
itunes et tout le monde connait c'est
vrai qu'on laissait
très important
par avait la top top des vertus des
vannes avait la même clarté la tuerie
oh
c'est d'être ici pas besoin de faire un
dessin
après mais je portais hanche est juste
elle se faire la planche
tiens voilà ton étalons qui enlève son
pantalon il c'est avec émotion je touche
aux fruits de la passion
grâce à ces choses à les renflouer
[Musique]
oui cet abruti l'anneau fabien de
l'étranger j'adore les pertes à opel
comme ses sauts qui doit tout faire pour
la contempler des débats il s'est fait
circoncire à l'émetteur du travail ou
non merci merci l'essai se dit
tranquille quoique liberty d'avoir été
avec tout mon chéri wilkinson qui s'est
touché la chatte à la voisine ne le fait
pas bien entendue au sens propre nom qui
devrait acter la tannerie
merci il va bien jean michel maire c'est
vrai au top mais il vous plaît je sais
tout à l'heure evo evo jean michel maire
il vous plaît à découvrir et peut
rallier rire il est très bien mais il
est très bien bonjour et vous moi j'ai
pas eu l'occasion de danser avec lui
donc vous voilà dans sa patrie
josie harris a glissé au pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur le plateau
basket-ball coup fumant cigarette ou sur
le bateau laura miclo n'y suffit pas
prévient toute l'équipe a tous eu le
chum et leur jeunesse